[Music]
favorite name I never smoked it's a
great name I'm Vance head
that's glad my dad didn't name me
Richard oh he's got him he's gone
oh good let me tell you some about me
this is this is my sweet spot that's
where I get all my yeah well you got a
little sweet spot there these dark ah I
think I know what are you messing your
pants up there oh I am sorry you got
actually have a hole going on down there
thank you though the show has a lot of
money dang we used to used to not even
till today anymore
Blake you send me an emoji for what
recently my emotion noop noop noop noop
ha ha I like his chair I can watch
football mister yeah okay I'm sorry
fangirling a little bit some to have a
loving girl I'm a fingerling all day
with these teas hi hi dancer that [ __ ]
out say the word out out stay out out
way out wow that's me I'm Mississippi
nevermind
sorry about that I saw faint healing
missed two lines ha ha I'll do that all
wrong thank you I need you every day Tim
I know in my life feel I'll hug you all
right yeah yeah I get a hug I was
nervous
don't just stand here and be like big
and tall we need you to like can you do
this
I bet you can't
oh hey five six seven kick two three
four kick what there's this make us
friends now yeah well yes only if you
can't work it's just me and Molly man
[ __ ] one to the what you don't want to
join in the date
what in the hell is happening oh you can
sing your ass off I'm sorry I'm cussing
because I should be doing that with you
yeah me like it's just a weird thing to
like say what is everything that comes
out of your mouth it rot
see y'all have like this written
[Music]